[Music]
there's little solace to be found in a
tragedy like this
but in the temple british woman bhavna
patel calls her second
home there is at least togetherness
[Music]
mother-in-law pratima prays for a
miracle that
bhavna american husband vishal and
one-year-old aishani who were on the
third floor of the tower
will be found alive
[Music]
bhavna is four months pregnant if the
collapse had been two days previously
she would have been here for a ritual
ceremony the lottery of circumstance is
agonizing
they're very more than family to me
their loved ones more than family
because they actually you know live in
this temple for a long time
i still cannot believe that they leave
us but
we just has to have a very strong bond
of the memory
families of the missing have been moved
to this hotel
they're receiving regular updates from
authorities but those briefings are
growing more tense by the day
as the desperation intensifies in one of
these meetings a woman whose sister is
missing
asks why there aren't more answers for
her
was there a sinkhole under that first
building so i just want to know
ma'am i i we're the fire department
we're first responders we have no idea
that's the structural engineers that's
the brother down there you mean to tell
me you can't tell what's original
parking lot and what may have came down
families were taken on a convoy of buses
to visit the collapse
site underneath this debris a trench has
been dug
125 feet long and 20 feet wide
to act as a fire break and allow better
access
rescue teams say though all power and
telecommunication
signals from the building are now gone i
realize this is a highly emotive issue
both for your men and women in the field
and also for the families
are you able to say when this search and
rescue effort
becomes a search and recovery operation
no at this time
i'm not hope and that's what i'm
focusing on
so i'm going to continue that as much as
possible that's the driving message
that's what we're looking for
it's a strange type of grief when there
is no certainty
this is one family's way of coping
across miami and beyond others are
forging their own way through the
heartache
martha kellner sky news florida